[Music]
okay so three of them this week let's
talk about toy story toy story toy story
for yes is a man [ __ ] the first one came
out when I was a kid this is the only
one that I actually saw I saw the first
two I don't think I saw the third one
perfectly enjoyable movie for a general
audience since that I would say there's
nothing wrong with it you know I was
just kind of pulled into it and just
went along for the ride yeah you know
kind of a classical story I'd say story
of you know adventure and loyalty and
then it ended up being a love story
between [ __ ] toys a lot of humor yeah
a lot of humor voice acting was really
good the animation was really good just
can't really complain about it I'm sure
it'll make money yeah I really liked it
I thought it started out like a little
bit but then you know what's the kind of
adventure got started like what's the
little girl that goes on the road trip
with you know if you've seen the trailer
you know that the whole thing is about
the little girl and she makes a toy at
school without a spork and his name is
for key yeah he doesn't understand how
he's alive because he's not supposed to
be a toy he just being trash so that was
that was kind of like funny like weird
just kept trying to throw himself away
of like what he was doing prevent it
yeah yeah but when he finally figures
out that he's a toy and stuff like that
so they go on this big long adventure I
have to say that I really like a lot of
these like original characters like
slinky dog and mr. Potato Head and stuff
like that we're not in it a lot I mean
they were kind of in it but there was
just like a PC into them but they did
introduce two new characters that were
like at a carnival called funny and
chicken and those two were a riot yeah I
really like this - I think bunny was
voiced by a Jordan feel now that I'm
thinking about it but yeah those two
were like really funny and I think those
are like the the best addition I have to
say I'm not gonna spoil the ending or
anything like that I was kind of
surprised that it ended the way it did
and I
don't know if they're going to make
anymore now you can think of it I wish
you could but it's like it's I don't
know it just seemed like the way they
ended I was like yeah you know I guess
it's possible I judge kids movies on
whether or not they'll drive an adult
crazy and this one was definitely not
driving adultery this one was like farts
and I don't mind like Janie kids movies
there's any animated movies this one not
really a knee no it really had like a
night a lot of heart and like and I
spent a lot of the Toy Story movies you
had that like they're just they're kind
of about friendship and like he said
about loyalty and like you know that but
particularly Woody's loyalty to his kin
and to you know him and his friendship
with Buzz and stuff like that so you
know we kind of explored that same thing
but it went into some other stuff too so
I really liked it I thought it was
adorable
yeah I recommend it's a good movie yeah
for what it is
you
okay next one we saw next we want to
talk about is yesterday yesterday yeah
yeah it was good it was kind of like a
Twilight Zone movie where a guy is now
in a parallel universe where the Beatles
don't exist and he's he's a
singer-songwriter and he uses what he
remembers of the Beatles songs to make
hits
and it becomes a love story really
there's not much to it I don't want to
steal any of the movies Thunder he you
know but that's basically the premise
which they kind of said it they said
right in a trailer see the trailer you
know that the premises I mean his name
is Jack Mallik he's like a failing
singer-songwriter and like he said
there's some kind of weird they don't
really explain it but there's just some
kind of weird weird like worldwide like
all the power goes out for like 12
seconds and he gets hit by a bus
yeah and then when he wakes up he's like
one of the only yeah it's like the only
thing that I thought was funny was that
there's other stuff that other people
don't remember yeah I actually don't
want to steal the movies yeah they're on
stuff like that so that's kind of a
spoiler I think but there's there's it's
not just the Beatles that are missing
yeah and it's it's it's pretty that
element that part of the movie I like
that element of it the movie was it was
a good movie although it wasn't as good
as I actually thought it was gonna be oh
I loved it I thought it was really good
I thought that the Edit would bogs down
a couple times where I was going like
come on now we can pick it up let's get
back to the story oh you know it was a
good movie I'm just saying it was there
were times it was kind of slow yeah I
didn't really find it well I didn't even
realize like when I'm a pace of the
movie for me was yeah god I saw the
trailer I didn't even realize that Danny
Boyle had directed this so I
like other movies too so that was kind
of a plus in my book um the thing that I
liked about this was that I mean this
story the characters particularly like
drew you in like right away I mean just
super charming like super endearing all
of the kit like all the friends but it's
got great humor wit yeah and like
they're all really funny but it's just
like a just very natural humor it's like
I really like British humor anyway and
that it was really well done in this and
the guy him Esch patel I guess this is
his first movie and I think he's a real
singer-songwriter so he does all his own
singing and this presumably I mean I
guess yeah he doesn't look like he's
like that and he's just like such a
charming like lead character and like
all his friends and stuff it's just like
really really funny and like all the
characters are really funny
there's just funny little situations and
it's just that the premise of it is
absurd but not like over-the-top like
you know what I mean like it's it's a
weird something happened yeah something
happened and he kind of slipped into a
parallel universe yeah like I said it's
just kind of like a mild fantasy nothing
wrong crazy happens or anything like
that but it's just kind of like one of
those things where it's just it goes
after the thing it is he's not
fantasizing about it it did happen yeah
you find out that it you know there's
more to it things unravel so it's not
just him yeah I mean it is something
that actually happened but it's not
really explained because they don't
understand yeah I didn't even realize
like until I was watching the movie I
was like
I didn't realize that if you woke up in
a world where the Beatles didn't exist
you would have to remember all their
songs yeah
from memory does not record their
recordings there's no sheet music that
he has Urich sheets or anything like
that and he has problems with some of
the song yeah so would you if you like
tried to like think of I remember there
would be any way to like check your
memory yeah it's situation yeah but I
recommend it it's good movie I really I
liked it a lot I probably liked it a lot
more than you did but only thing I only
thing I didn't like about it is that in
a couple spots kind of slowed down a
little bit I'm so go come on let's go
I get it I get it we don't need to talk
you know I probably would have added it
a good ten minutes out okay you know I
mean but it just would've been a little
stuff like yeah not so much dialogue but
lingering too long on a shot weird
transmissions that took too long it was
it yeah it tried to be a little too
overly sentimental when I understood the
sentiment yeah it kind of wallowed in
emotion a little bit too much for me but
then again that's just me there was a
lot of women in the audience they were
loving that movie yeah when we walked
out it was most a lot of females I heard
them say how wonderful that movie was
like I said I think guys have kind of a
shorter attention span oh yeah for
emotional scenes yeah okay come on yeah
you loved her so I think drive a truck
yeah this drive truck she wasn't shut up
let's get back to the story I was gonna
say I love the woman that plays like the
record executives like she's kind of
like the villain or whatever she was
like funny she just the ballbreaker yeah
I really really liked this movie a lot
like I was gonna say and I might have
mentioned this in our review of Rocket
Man but it kind of had a same and
obviously it's gonna have a similar vibe
as across the universe and you know
because that was beetles too and it's
kind of it's not as fantastic fantastic
with that but um you know less Fanta
like more of a realistic fantasy if you
want to what is that
but yeah I really recommend it I like it
a lot
okay we got to talk about what does it
Annabel returned Annabel comes Annabel
comes home I think I've seen like four
from this universe yeah
what's the name of the guy who makes
these things James Wan James Wan yeah
they're the conjuring was the first one
yeah like there's all kind of sheets
what they are is like really high budget
episodes of The Haunting odd and then a
lot of these stories were featured on
the Honda they were right there just
there just told a lot better with more
sensationalized and better special
effects bigger budgets and this one's no
exception
I actually the last one we saw was La
Llorona
yeah and liar oh no [ __ ] is scared
reading for the first half and then it
outstayed his welcome it became not
scary after a while yeah this one was
kind of the opposite it would it was
kind of slow the first it has slow setup
but it was yeah but once it started
rolling I think I liked it better than
La Llorona yeah in a way in a way it
kind of it kind of had a better liar
onna started off with a bang
BAM and then it almost kind of got
absurd they showed it too much and yeah
that was that was this one kind of this
this one kind of had a normal structure
for a horror movie where it starts off
kind of slowly and then it builds up and
then it ends I liked it I mean you
finally get the seat you finally get to
see ed Warren's at Warren's [ __ ]
werewolf you get this the catch of this
movie really when you think about what
you really break it down when you really
break it down to it to its to its
essence is the Chinese would love this
movie because they like to see pretty
people on camera they'll paint if see
pretty I've seen I've read their reviews
or like why these actors so ugly
everybody in this movie is cute it's
three cute girls fighting [ __ ] demons
and some of the demons are cute yeah
they range from probably about one 12 to
18 prolly well the little girl was
supposed to be 11
that's the Warrens daughter yeah there
were two older girls like a babysitter
and like the babysitter's friends yeah I
bet that girl wasn't 11 though I bet
that girl well probably not but yeah
this one um like you said it's and I'm
all and I like slow burn horror movies
this one did take a little while to get
going cuz I'm there thinking to myself
I'm like is this like hanging around the
house yeah the movie but you know yeah I
kind of like that they do that slow
because I was expecting like jump scares
in your face like every five seconds
which it has a little bit of that yeah
um
they do kind of [ __ ] with you a little
bit so they're just kind of like oh then
it's the teenagers love this movie
though I heard him back there they do
yeah it was like almost full and every
year they were just like flipping out
yeah they had the cute boyfriend
fighting the [ __ ] the werewolf they
had the funny ass [ __ ] pizza delivery
boy that [ __ ] he killed it for like 60
seconds is my favorite yeah yeah
as soon as the pizza delivery boy shows
up I like the movie well it doesn't take
I mean it takes itself seriously but
there's moments in it yeah bit of levity
where you can see that they're kind of
like winking at you yeah that's I think
that's a weakness of these movies is
that the tone they take themselves as
very serious yeah what I have to say I
mean the thing about this one because
it's Annabelle Annabelle actually she's
I guess she's in it a lot but the movie
is kind of like not as much focused on
her as focused on her being like a
conduit for other spirits which means
that they can kind of have like an
all-star cast if like all those demons
and werewolves you know dudes with coins
on their eyes and like also they have
all kind of like you know wedding yeah
those that are cells dead I really
couldn't follow the story I don't even
know if the story made sense
I just really but it's very just simple
yeah to me it was just like going
through a haunted house and they were
showing me stuff it was like that thing
like they didn't analyze it to see if it
made sense or not there didn't seem to
be a lot of content
there it's a lot of cool visual effects
the things with the coins the eyes there
were some scenes they're the coolest
visual yeah there were some scenes that
were very effective yeah I think that
was like yeah definitely the coolest
visuals in the movie were that were
those things
yeah the ferryman ghosts walking through
all the damp walking around the camera
walking through all the walls that was
pretty good yeah there's a lot of like
cool shots yeah but you know it's like I
said it was a very simple story and it's
very contained yeah there was only
really there was a few scenes at the
beginning where like the little girl was
at school and like the older girls were
like at the grocery store or something
but other than that it pretty much all
took place in one house it just heads
house Lorraine's house yeah you know in
their little like Museum and they're
like you know in the hallway in the
kitchen and stuff so the whole thing
pretty much takes place in one place um
but you know ed is such a badass he
actually in this movie
Edie exorcised a demon just a film of
Edie exorcise the demon in this are the
characters that play the actors that
play them um we're actually not in this
very much they were kind of in the
beginning and then the end so they were
just kind of like well we're
contractually obligated to be in another
one of these conjuring movies yeah
because they're on all of them but you
know it's a serviceable movie I mean
it's a circus full summer horror movie
well like he said I think I actually
liked it better than a little bit better
than liar onna and I liked it better
than the nun yes and I kind of forgot
about it all right yeah it was it was
good when I was watching it but I got I
forgot about it so I think this one I
don't know if I'm gonna like remember
much about it but it was like fun to
watch you know for what it is yeah the
conjuring movies you know they're decent
[Music]